>>Presenter: I'm delighted to welcome to the
Googleplex Kelly McGonigal, a health psychologist
at Stanford University and the author of a
new book, "The Willpower Instinct."
So in life, sometimes we struggle with choices
and accomplishing goals and we often believe
that sheer willpower will get us there.
But much of what we believe and know about
willpower could actually be wrong, or that's
what Kelly discovered in working with students
at Stanford University where she teaches at
Stanford University School of Medicine and
the Stanford Center for Compassion.
So she created a course called the Science
of Willpower at Stanford School of Continuing
Studies and it became one of the most popular
courses at the school and went on to be a
hugely successful blog at Psychology Today
and now a book which you can get your hands
on at the end of this talk.
And Kelly said, if she has her way, it'll
soon be an action figure and an action movie,
too.
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: Willpower!
>>Presenter: So today Kelly's gonna talk about
how we can accomplish the array of goals that
we often struggle to get done.
It might be a healthier lifestyle, it might
be life of greater productivity or sometimes
something as simple as having waited for 6
months, finally, finally, finally clearing
out the closet.
[Kelly chuckles] So please help me welcome
Kelly McGonigal.
[Applause]
>>Kelly McGonigal: Thank you.
Hello.
I've been giving a lot of talks in this last
month and a lot about New Year's resolutions
and I have to say this is the first place
I've talked where there's apparently a healthy
code resolution going on.
Is that right?
Did I see these signs right?
So who's still keeping their healthy code
resolution?
Anyone?
Good, congratulations you've got some willpower.
Um, why don't you tell me just to sort of
get things rolling, tell me something that
has challenged your willpower today, anyone.
>>audience member: Getting up on time.
>>Kelly McGonigal: Getting up on time.
>>audience member: Washing the dishes.
>>Kelly McGonigal: Washing the dishes.
Okay, so we've got two kinds of "I Will-Power"
challenges.
Something you have to make yourself do even
though it'd be a little bit easier to just
not do it.
Something else?
Yeah?
>>audience member: Doing yoga for back pain.
>>Kelly McGonigal: Doing yoga for back pain,
well, I'm glad to hear that.
We're you at my talk two years ago about yoga
for pain?
That's great.
Another "I Will" challenge.
Something else, yeah?
>>audience member: [Inaudible]
>>Kelly McGonigal: Yeah, so an example of
"I Won't" power.
There's all these links you could follow and
you could just click and get lost down the
link hole and you have to find the ability
to resist that temptation.
Maybe one or two more?
[Pause]
>>Kelly McGonigal?
Anything?
Back row, any willpower challenges?
[Audience members shout]
>>Kelly McGonigal: Lunch options for today.
Have you had your lunch yet?
>>audience member: [Inaudible]
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: So
>>audience member: [Inaudible]
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: Great, so we make lots
of decisions everyday about what to eat and
what to do.
Okay, well, these are all great examples of
willpower challenges and I wanna just start
with a little definition, my definition of
willpower or willpower challenge.
And I define a willpower challenge as something
that is basically a competition between two
parts of yourself.
Neuroscientists are famous for saying that
even though we have only one brain we actually
have two minds and we are completely different
people depending on which mind is active or
which systems of the brain are more active.
So, a willpower challenge is anything where
those two versions of yourself have competing
goals.
So, for example, there may be a part of you
that really wants to eat a candy bar for your
snack and then there's a part of you that
actually has some longer term goals, you're
thinking health, you're thinking weight loss,
you're thinking bikini season, whatever, and
maybe the banana seems like the better snack.
And, again, both of these choices you may
be drawn to by different parts of your mind
or two different versions of yourself and
one of the things that has really influenced
my work with willpower is thinking about it
in terms of what's going on in the brain.
And we're gonna talk about that a little bit
today, the fact that you could be the very
same person but depending on your mindset,
depending on your energy, depending on your
stress levels, your brain is gonna meet this
willpower challenge in a different way and
you're gonna end up making, you know, one
choice today and one choice tomorrow.
So, as was mentioned, this book is based on
a class that I teach at Stanford called "The
Science of Willpower" those are our actual
students I'm not sure what I said that was
funny but those are actual Science of Willpower
students.
And I created this course because I was going
around trying to teach people how to be more
productive, how to improve their health and
everywhere I went people said, "Oh, we know
we're supposed to do that stuff already, we
just don't want to do it."
And there was this really interesting fundamental
gap between what people wanted and what they
thought they wanted.
But as people were very identified, you could
say, with this version of the self.
People felt like deep down that they were
the person who wanted the candy bar and this
other person that wanted the banana, "Like,
who is that?
That's not really me."
I realized that people didn't just need to
know what is the right thing to do or what
is the healthy thing to do or tips for stress
management or productivity, they needed to
feel like this person.
And they needed to know how to be that person
as the default rather than walking around
always feeling like they had to resist this
core self that only wants immediate gratification
or never wants to do anything difficult.
Okay, so that's how the class came about.
What is with my clicker?
There we go, okay, great.
So, I thought today, since this is a class
based on science, that I would share with
you five of my favorite experiments from the
class and from the book and I chose experiments
that I like because they use tiny interventions,
really, really small interventions to shape
people's behavior and they have very large
outcomes.
I think this is the kind of thing many of
us are looking for, one small change we can
make, whether it's a change in how we think
or change in the way that we're approaching
the willpower challenge that can have huge
payoffs down the road making it easier to
do what it really is deep down that we want
even when it's sometimes difficult, or part
of us doesn't want.
Okay, let's start with the first experiment.
How many of you sometimes feel like this guy?
I know at least one of you only had 3 hours
of sleep last night.
So it turns out when you're this version of
yourself, every willpower challenge is more
difficult.
And the first intervention I wanna tell you
about is actually a sleep intervention.
The main intervention was trying to help people
sleep more or sleep better.
And it was people had a very serious willpower
challenge, these are people who are recovering
from an addiction to drugs.
And they were in a substance abuse recovery
program.
And half of the people in the standard care
were assigned to take a mindfulness meditation
training that was designed to help them improve
their sleep or sleep more.
So the first thing I want you to take a look
at on this graph, this is minutes of sleep
per night and you're gonna think this is insanely
optimistic, I know, but everyone's starting
around 7 hours and we're gonna improve on
7 hours.
That probably seems impossible dream.
Okay, so everyone in the group was starting
around 7 hours and what the researchers found
was that just doing a little bit of meditation
every day, breath focus meditation, increased
sleep time to just over 8 hours a day and
the control group had a little bit of deterioration
to slightly less than 7 hours of sleep a night.
Now that's not the interesting finding.
I mean, it is nice to know that if you meditate
for a few minutes a day you will sleep better
and get more sleep.
So what's interesting is that change in sleep
time then made these recovering addicts impervious
to relapse, they were stronger against relapse
and this is a very high correlation, .70,
the increase in sleep time predicted resistance
to relapse with a correlation of .70.
Getting one more hour of sleep a night suddenly
made it a lot easier for these recovering
addicts to resist the temptation of falling
off the wagon.
And interestingly, the number, I never know
where, it's gonna bounce off the screen right?
I should point at the screen?
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: You guys are tech experts.
The number of minutes per day that people
meditated also predicted resistance to relapse.
So there were really two things going on in
this intervention, there was getting more
sleep and there was also something about the
actual practice time and it wasn't a lot,
it was something like 10 minutes a day, 15
minutes a day.
And both of these things, sleep and meditation,
were giving people more willpower for one
of the biggest willpower challenges.
So I want us to think together a little bit
about why those two small interventions, an
hour more sleep or 10 minutes of meditation
a day, might actually give us more willpower
for any willpower challenge.
What you're looking at here is an image from
an FMRI study about what happens to the brain
when you are a little bit sleep deprived.
And most studies use less than 6 hours of
sleep a night as sleep deprived which may
seem normal to you but for most of us that's
actually functioning far suboptimal.
What you're looking at here is a composite
of a lot of different people's brains, some
who are sleep deprived and some who are not.
And we're gonna slice the brain, so imagine
me standing this way and we're gonna have
one of those meat slicers and we're gonna
slice down the head and just start taking
sections off and look down the middle.
So where you see these yellow spots, that's
the front of the brain, right about here or
right about here, if that were my brain pointing
that way.
And yellow means that this area of the brain
is under activated when you have less than
6 hours of sleep at night.
This area of the brain is unable to do its
job as efficiently and the red areas are areas
that are more activated, sort of midbrain
regions that are associated with basic impulses
and instincts.
So when you're getting less than 6 hours of
sleep a night your brain is actually unable
to recruit the systems of the brain that you
need to be that better version of yourself.
This area of the brain, I love this image
because it's like, here's where the balance
is weighed, "Do I want the weight loss or
do I want the chocolate bar?"
And this area of the brain right here is basically
keeping track of your goals and it's sort
of hard job, its heavy lifting it needs to
do is to remember long term goals, core values
and when it is unable to do that, when it's
under fueled or when it's under active, your
brain thinks all it really wants, all you
really want is the chocolate bar or to procrastinate
or to follow that link through, or to not
bother doing your yoga exercises.
And so, in some key way, the ability to remember
who you are and what your big goals are is
dependent on the ability of this area of the
brain to use energy well and sleep deprivation
is one of the main things that can get in
the way of that.
And I think that's one of the reasons why
this small sleep intervention ended up helping
people resist relapse to drug addiction because
they now have brains that were better fueled
to remember their goals to stay clean and
sober.
And it's not just sleep that impacts the physiology
of your brain, how well your brain uses energy.
There are a couple of other things that seem
to really strengthen the ability of the brain's
frontal regions to do what they're supposed
to do, to help you control impulses and find
your motivation.
Here are the four things from the research
that seem to do it, to make your brain a kind
of willpower machine.
One is sleep, as I mentioned, and hopefully
there's gonna be one thing on this list that
you're not currently doing that you're willing
to do cause you don't have to do all four.
So getting a little bit more sleep makes the
prefrontal cortex better able to regulate
those systems of the brain the direct you
towards temptation and immediate gratification.
And meditation also, and both meditation and
physical exercise have been shown to make
not only your brain more efficient at using
these self control systems but they actually
make these systems bigger and better connected
to the regions that they are supposed to be
controlling.
And, again, it can be a very quick time course
to see these benefits.
People who meditate maybe 10 minutes a day,
after a couple months their brains look different,
these regions are bigger and better connected.
People who work out on a regular basis who
used to be sedentary, again, studies show
that in as little as a couple of months of
regular workouts, their prefrontal cortices
are bigger and denser and better connected.
So these are two things that you can do that
actually train the physiology of your willpower.
The last thing that the research suggests
is what you eat has a very big influence on
whether or not your brain is able to be this
better version of yourself.
There's something about having big, big spikes
in blood sugar levels and then big drops in
blood sugar levels that really screws up how
the brain uses energy and you need your brain
to be like an energy efficient machine if
you're gonna be walking around the world in
that kind of better-you mindset rather than
that basic-impulse-you.
So, research shows that shifting to eating
a more plant based diet actually changes the
way the brain functions and has a lot to do
with what's going on with your blood sugar
levels.
So these are things that we sometimes think
of as requiring willpower, right?
We think, "Okay, I have to sit down and force
myself meditate.
I have to work out.
I have to say no to the donut and eat something
that has fiber in it for breakfast."
But we rarely think about the fact that actually
not doing these things may be part of what
makes it so difficult to begin and there's
kind of a curve where when we first start
it feels like we're using willpower but everything
on this list that takes a little bit of willpower
to begin with ends up giving you back far
more willpower than they take and not just
for these challenges.
It's not just that exercising makes it easier
to exercise, studies show that exercising
makes it easier to eat right, to not spend
too much money, to stop procrastinating, to
pay better attention, all of these things
have a kind of global training effect on what
you could think of as your willpower muscle.
Was there a question up front or a comment?
[Skips question]
>>Kelly McGonigal: So the question was why
does it say low glycemic and plant based?
There's actually more evidence that a vegan
diet does this better than a diet that is
low glycemic and includes animal products
but I'm not sure that that's entirely realistic
for everyone, so I think you can kind of pick
which way you're willing to go with that.
Both low glycemic and plant based help.
But if you look at just the physiology of
it, there's more evidence for the plant based
diet.
Okay, so let me go on to the next experiment.
So the first experiment was just get some
more sleep.
The second experiment, I want you to think
about a recent set back you had or kind of
a will power failure.
Maybe it was not eating the healthy thing
at lunch, maybe it was not doing your exercise
in the morning, maybe it was spending all
morning long following links that had nothing
to do with your project.
So I want you to think of a recent time when
you had some kind of willpower failure.
[Pause]
>>Kelly McGonigal: Does anyone need to borrow
one of mine?
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: You guys got one?
Okay, so my question for you is do you think
that feeling bad about that, presumably feeling
maybe a little bit of regret, a little bit
of guilt about it, a little bit of self criticism
about that, does that help us improve next
time?
Does that, can that be a real source of future
willpower?
Raise your hand if you think that feeling
bad can actually be a real source of willpower
to improve the next time.
Hands up.
And how many of you think that that feeling
bad is actually going to be a further drain
on willpower?
Yeah, great.
Maybe some of you have read that chapter in
the book.
So I wanna talk now about some of the research
that tends to surprise people the most.
When I first started teaching this class,
this was the research people argued with,
like literally couldn't get them to be quiet
in the classroom because they were so convinced
this couldn't possibly be true.
This is a study looking at whether it's better
to let yourself off the hook for your mistakes
in terms of preventing future willpower collapses.
So this particular study, that I'm gonna talk
about in a little more detail, brought in
people who were trying to manage their weight
and eat healthy.
And they gave them an immediate willpower
failure.
They showed up for the study and they were
forced to eat a donut.
And they even had to choose the flavor of
donut they were gonna eat so they would feel
complicit in this willpower failure.
And they had to drink a whole glass of water
too so they'd feel a little bit uncomfortably
full.
Okay, so we have everyone, dieters here having,
now, a willpower failure, they just ate this
donut and the next part of the study is a
taste test where they are given a lot of different
types of candy and they're said, "You know,
we want you to evaluate all these candies
so please just eat as much as you need to,
as much as you want so that you can evaluate
these candies."
And, of course, these candies were all pre
weighed so that experimenters could find out
exactly how much candy the dieters ate after
they had blown their diet with a donut.
And in this particular study the researchers
had a hypothesis.
They thought that the guilt that dieters experience
when they fall off their diet actually really
undermines future self control.
So they wanted to create an intervention that
would basically get rid of the guilt and shame
that people feel when they make a mistake.
So in this study, half the dieters were randomly
assigned to receive a special "letting themselves
off the hook" message.
So between the donut eating and the taste
test, an experimenter came in and said something
very simple, they said, "By the way we've
realized now that some people in this experiment
feel guilty after eating the donut."
So there was an opportunity for people to
recognize they might be feeling guilty.
Second part of the message, "We want you to
remember that actually everyone indulges sometimes
and we asked you to do it."
So there's a kind of putting it in a broader
perspective and the last part of the message
was a simple plea, "Please don't be too hard
on yourself about it."
Okay, so very simple.
You might be feeling guilty, remember everyone
does it, don't be hard on yourself about it
and then they went on to the taste test.
And what the researchers found is that the
women that had been given the self forgiveness
message ate less than half as much candy as
women who had not been told, "Don't worry
about it.
It's not a big deal" which is exactly the
opposite of what most people think, most people
think you make a mistake, you have a willpower
failure and you start saying nice things to
yourself about it that this could only lead
to disaster.
It would lead to licensing even more indulgence
and yet, that's exactly the opposite of what
was found in this study and not just this
study but in a lot of different studies now.
This is one of the, sort of, strongest pieces
of theory we have in willpower research right
now.
That is, the harder you are on yourself when
you have a willpower failure, the more likely
you are to have the same failure again and
the bigger it's gonna be when you do.
For example, one study took a look at problem
drinkers and had them keep track of how much
they were drinking and how bad they felt the
morning after.
What they found is the people who were the
most self critical and felt the most ashamed
or guilty about drinking the night before
wanted to drink more immediately when they
woke up and also drank more that night and
the next.
There was something about the self critical
nature and the shame and the guilt that was
driving people back to the very thing they
felt bad about.
The same has been shown for addiction including
quitting smoking, you know, you have that
first relapse and the more you beat yourself
up about it the more you now need to be comforted
with something, probably the very thing that
you're feeling bad about because that's probably
why you do it in the first place.
The same has been shown for gambling, the
more people feel guilty and self critical
about losing money, they more likely they
are to borrow money and try to win it back
and end up losing more.
And even for procrastination, you may not
have any kind of addictions but even for procrastination,
researchers show that the harder someone is
on putting, the harder someone is for putting
something off, the longer they procrastinate
the next time.
And all this has to do with the basic fact
that when we are feeling stressed out and
guilty and ashamed, that is a state that puts
us into the version of ourselves, the mindset
that is much more susceptible to immediate
gratification, temptation and anxiety.
It's basically the biological opposite of
what needs to be happening in your brain and
body to remember your long term goals and
to be that other version of yourself.
What we would call the willpower version of
yourself.
And as soon as you start piling on the guilt
and the shame, your brain switches into that
other mode in which now everything's gonna
be more tempting including procrastinating
or including smoking or drinking.
So I just wanted to give you a sense of what
it would be like to give yourself a self compassion
message.
Again, I said, this was a tiny intervention,
this donut study.
And this is basically all it was.
And there are a number of programs now that
are teaching people how to write these messages
for themselves and literally have them scripted
for the moment they fail, for the moment that
they procrastinated and they're late again,
for that moment when they had that cigarette
when they hadn't smoked in a week and to be
able to whip this message out as a way of
not falling down that hole that we often fall
into.
So the three steps of this message are the
first is mindfulness of what you're thinking
and feeling.
Noticing that you're feeling guilty or noticing
that you're feeling self doubt or self critical,
maybe angry at yourself and to actually allow
yourself to see those feelings because a big
reason that people go from feeling guilty
to giving in again is they just want to get
rid of that feeling, it's so kind of overwhelming
and they want to distract themselves from
it with something that is gonna get them into
further trouble.
And then the second step is this common humanity.
One of the reasons that it is hard to find
our motivation and our willpower is we start
to feel there's something uniquely broken
with us.
There's something about who we are that is
wrong and weak and that mindset makes it very
difficult to tap back into your motivation
or your strength.
So this message of common humanity is basically
saying to yourself, "You know what?
This is part of the process of change, this
is how things get done.
Sometimes we procrastinate.
Sometimes we fall off the wagon.
Everyone is imperfect."
And to recognize that this is not saying anything
about who you are, it's saying something about
the process and what matters is how you respond
afterward, not the fact that it happened at
all.
And then this last step is encouragement over
criticism.
And if you were to think about someone you
were mentoring, you know, some of you probably
have mentees here or interns or you think
about a child that you care about or a dear
friend, what would you say to them when they
had a set back?
And to say that to yourself, it might be reminding
yourself of your goal, it might be reminding
yourself of the big picture rather than the
sort of, the micro picture in which you feel
like a failure.
And to do that rather than the voices we often
have in our head that are saying things like,
"Why did you do that again?
You're so stupid.
You're never going to change."
And to actually start to talk to yourself
a little bit in the second person as if you
were a good friend.
And research shows that this particular approach,
learning how to talk to yourself in this way
is more effective, for example, at quitting
smoking than nicotine replacement therapy.
That's how powerful being able to respond
to set backs with compassion can be.
I want you to take a look at these circles
which go from being totally non overlapping
to extremely overlapping and you're gonna
decide which of these sets of circles best
represent how you feel about who you are today
and who you're gonna be, let's say, 30 years
from now, 30 years in the future, or pick
a time period that feels right to you.
Okay, so this is your current self and this
if your future self 30 years from now.
This means who you are today is really very
different than who you're gonna be 30 years
from now.
Some overlap but actually a lot of change
is gonna be happening between now, who knows,
then this last set of circles this is like,
you know what, who I am today is probably
who I'm gonna be in 30 years, same me.
Okay, so you're gonna pick for yourself.
Take another few seconds and think where you
are on this graph.
Actually, let's do a kind of rolling wave
cause I'm actually curious if there's a trend
here at Google.
Just put your hand up when you see your circle
highlighted.
Who's over here?
Over here?
Okay, over here?
Oh you guys are normally distributed, this
is great, who's over here?
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: Who's over here?
And who's over here?
Yeah, pretty good, pretty good.
That was great.
Okay, so it turns out where you put yourself
on this map has a lot to do with some very
important willpower challenges related to
health and money and even moral behavior.
Don't feel too bad if you're at an extreme
tail that is not associated with willpower
cause I'm gonna show you some strategies for
being able to get to the end that is associated
with willpower if you need it.
Okay, so let me start with the first intervention
and this was an intervention that was done
here at Stanford University and this was using
undergraduate students who are very young
and it was a virtual reality experiment where
undergraduate students came into the laboratory
and the researchers had carefully created
3D avatars of the student themselves.
So if I came into the laboratory I would be
meeting a 3D avatar of myself at retirement
age.
It was a really great set up in which you
got all their virtual reality equipment on,
hearing and seeing, and it feels like you
are sitting across the table from your future
self and it's set up with cameras in such
a way that if I move my left hand like this
it looks like my future self is also moving
their hand and if I talk it looks like my
future self is talking back.
And in the study the college students were
invited to interview their future selves,
to say things like, "Hey future Kelly, what's
going on right now?
What's really important in your life right
now?"
And then they had to answer the question.
So they would see their, I would see future
Kelly describing what's important in my life
at retirement age.
And this went on for about an hour, getting
to know their future selves.
And the reason the researchers decided to
do this intervention is because they discovered
that most of us feel like our future self
is a stranger.
And all of you who are on that first half
of the distribution, sort of you're thinking
about your future self and you don't really
know who that is, they could be really an
improvement on this model or it could just
be an older version of this model, we don't
know.
But what researchers found is that the more
you feel like your future self is a stranger,
is different than you, the less likely you
are to do things to protect that future selves
health and happiness.
Because why would you bother saving money
for some stranger when you could spend it
today on someone you know and love?
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: So in this particular experiment
after they had gotten to know their future
self, there was some time elapsed cause they
didn't want it to be totally obvious what
was going on, there's some time elapsed and
they brought people back and had them divvy
up $1,000 in a budgeting task.
And they pretended like they were interested
in how people made budgeting decisions.
But what they found is that the college students
who had met and interacted with their future
self ended up allotting more than twice as
much money into a retirement account than
college students who had not met their future
self.
College students who had not met their future
selves were more likely to want allot that
money to their present expenses or just to
some fun splurge.
And this research has actually had a lot of
impact in the world of retirement savings
and banking.
I just heard in an economist recommend last
week that we should be trying to Photoshop
pictures of people's future selves on every
mortgage application or credit card application
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: So people would really
have to think about the implications of this.
I mean, you can imagine an HR setting, right,
where people are a new employee and they're
asked to make their retirement allocations,
well, what if they had to interact with their
future self first?
New college students coming in to a first
job, might make a very big difference in their
retirement savings down the line.
Okay, so that was just one, that was the intervention,
that was the experiment but I just wanna point
more broadly to some of the research, looking
at that circle graph that I showed you, and
it turns out that people who believe that
there is more overlap, that they are more
closely related to their future self have
a lot more willpower for different types of
willpower challenges.
Oops!
I didn't mean to do that.
The first thing is they're less likely to
procrastinate in general and less likely to
be late.
One of my favorite findings from this research
is that people who had, who felt like they
were less similar to their future self were
also more likely to show up late for the experiment
or skip it completely, to just blow it off.
That was a kind of interesting finding.
They also are more comfortable, I'm sorry,
are more likely to make ethical decisions
at work.
So people who think their future self is more
different, like a total stranger, they're
actually more likely to feel good about betraying
a colleague at work if it helps them advance
in their career.
They're more likely to keep money that they
found even when they might have an inkling
who that money belongs to and that's kind
of an interesting finding cause we could understand
retirement, you know, future self, but it
seems like this ability to disconnect from
the long term consequences of your choices
actually primes you to be that more impulsive
self even when it doesn't really have anything
to do with your own long term benefits.
Then also, looking at real world outcomes
not just an experiment, but you look at what
circle people choose and how much money they
have, their assets, their home, their debt,
their wealth and people who feel closer to
their future self actually have more assets,
are more likely to own their home outright,
more money in the bank, more retirement savings.
So this is a real world finding not just an
experiment.
And they're also more likely to do things
that don't have a payoff immediately, like
flossing and exercising but that would be
good to protect their future self.
So with that in mind, one of my favorite willpower
boosting strategies that you can do that doesn't
really take any willpower at all, is to get
to know your future self.
And there are, you, you, actually here maybe
you can do 3D avatars, is that something,
is that a Google project somewhere?
[Laughter]
>>audience member: We can't tell you.
>>Kelly McGonigal: Can't tell you.
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: So most people can't actually
interact with their future self in that high
tech a way but it seems like there are other
ways that work as well.
One is to write a letter from your future
self to your present self and you can do this
in a number of different ways.
One way is just write to your present self
about who you are, what you're doing, where
you're living, what you care about.
Or you could write a more closely defined
letter that looks at some challenge you're
dealing with now.
Maybe you're struggling to quit some addiction
or spend time with your family or just something
that is seems like it's just not working the
way you would like it to.
And you could write a letter from your future
self thanking your present self for doing
it and describing what it was you did and
why it mattered.
And research suggests that this kind of letter
writing from your future self can actually
give yourself more willpower.
Yes?
>>male audience member: Does this boomerang
if you actually have low self esteem now telling
yourself you're gonna be more like you are
now in the future?
>>Kelly McGonigal: That is probably not the
letter you should write
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: So just for the people
who are watching this on the video the question
was, if you feel really bad about yourself
now could this have the opposite effect where
you think, "Oh my God, I'm never gonna change"
and if you're a loser now you're always gonna
be a loser so the letter might be like, "Dear
loser, I'm still a loser.
You're still a loser.
Life sucks."
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: That is not the letter.
Actually, so research suggests it is better
to be optimistic in this letter than to be
pessimistic.
But at the same time, so the key thing about
this finding is not so much whether you think
you're going to be exactly the same, but whether
you understand that it's going to be the same
person having the future experience.
And that, which actually comes to the second
point here, so that's actually a different
thing.
It's not like, are you still going to have
all the same problems and all of the same
neuroses or have you fixed them?
It's not that kind of same self different
self it's do you understand that, like you
know how real pain is right now if I were
to come and punch you, how much that would
hurt?
Do you understand that 30 years from now it's
gonna hurt if someone punches you?
That seems to be the thing that people actually
have problems with.
When they think about their future selves
they don't have access to those emotions,
they don't understand that that future happiness
is going to be as real and as important.
So when you're doing this kind of letter writing
or doing this future self imagination, the
actual critical part is getting to feel like
that future self is real and that it is in
some way you.
That you are going to be the one having this
experience.
And it's not so much whether you think you're
going to be the identical person still listening
to the same music you listened to in 1983
or not like that.
Okay, so here's the second future self exercise
that gets to that.
And I call this going back to the future.
And this is the exercise of just imagining
yourself in the future.
Studies show that just imagining yourself
grocery shopping in the future, okay, not
like not anything even relevant to your goals
but just grocery shopping then ends up helping
people make better decisions in the present
moment that's going to lead to pay off in
the future because you can actually imagine
it.
You can imagine what would be on the shelf
and you know what it feels like to be pushing
a shopping cart and there's something about
making the future real that gives us more
willpower kind of independent of the content,
what you're thinking about.
But there's also studies showing that you
can imagine specific futures related to your
willpower challenge and both good sort of
future realities and negative future realities
can be very motivating.
So in one study they had people who wanted
to improve their health, to imagine the consequences
of not making a change, like really vividly,
what's that gonna be like?
What's it gonna feel like ten years from now
if you don't make this change?
And they had another group thinking about
the positive consequences of making the change
and what would that be like and how are you
gonna feel?
And both of those sort of future thinking,
ended up increasing the good health behavior
in the present.
So you guys have seen Back to the Future two,
right?
You guys have seen Back to the Future two?
You know he goes into the future and there's
like a really bad future and a really good
future, okay, at some point that reference
is not going to work anymore.
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: Okay, here's, so we got
two more interventions and this next intervention
I just wanna take a poll.
So we're talking about visualizing things,
if you had to guess which would be more helpful
for finding your willpower, do you think it's
more helpful to imagine or visualize yourself
failing or is it more helpful to visualize
and imagine yourself succeeding?
Raise your hand if you think imaging failure
is gonna be more helpful.
Raise your hand if you think imagine success.
You guys are such typical Americans.
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: Okay, that's what everyone
thinks.
So, actually it turns out imagining failure
is way more helpful than imagining success.
Not that imagining success is always bad but
imagining failure is better.
So let me tell you about this one intervention
and then some of the theory a little bit more
broadly.
In this particular study they took women from
young adult to middle age, a little bit older
adult all of whom were not exercising at all
and all of whom had the goal to exercise and
some of those women were randomly assigned
to your typical it's good to exercise, here's
why you should exercise, now think about your
goal and imagine yourself doing it, very typical.
And the other half were randomly assigned
to what they called an obstacle condition
where they had to imagine themselves failing.
They had to ask themselves, "When are you
gonna not exercise?
What is the obstacle going to be?
When is it gonna happen?
What are you gonna do if that happens?"
And they had people write about that every
single day.
They had to write out, when are you gonna
not exercise?
What are you gonna say to yourself that allows
you not to exercise?
When's it gonna happen?
How's it gonna happen and what are you gonna
do when you start to recognize that stuff
happening?
So the women were becoming kind of detectives
of their own failure and every day they revised
what they were writing based on what they
noticed.
"I didn't exercise cause I told myself I'll
do it later, I'll do it later, I'll do it
later, now it's time to go to sleep."
Or, "I didn't do it because I go so busy at
work then I didn't have my sneakers so I didn't
do it."
And they became very clear about how they
fail and they were able to predict future
failures from that.
Here's what the results were, it had an immediate
effect of doubling the amount of time they
were exercising.
So the very first week they started to predict
their failures in this way, they doubled to
102 minutes of exercise a week and that's
getting pretty close to the amount of exercise
that you need to have very serious health
benefits, both mental health and physical
health.
There was a much smaller improvement here
in the group of women who were given the standard,
"You wanna exercise.
Exercise is great, let's do it!"
And 16 weeks, so 4 months after that study,
the women who had been predicting their failure
had maintained and were exercising twice as
much as the women who were in the basic 'let's
exercise, here's why it's good'.
This is the thing that always blows people's
minds.
There is a lot of studies that show tracking
your success leads people to slack off in
the long run but nobody believes it.
So you probably heard how important it is
to keep track of your success because we feel
really good when we're able to write down
that we did something, right?
You know you feel something really good and
you're like, "Yes!
Check it off!"
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: Some people make to do
lists just so they can check stuff off.
And we know how good we feel when we're able
to write down and record our successes and
we mistake that feeling good as motivation
to do more.
But a number of studies show that when people
are reminded of their success and take note
of their progress they are much more likely
to then do something inconsistent with their
goal.
So if you are somebody, for example, there's
studies of dieters where people come in and
the experimenter says, "By the way, we wanted
to let you know how much progress you've made
on losing weight.
You're this close to your goal, you've been
doing great."
And on the way out of the lab, "Would you
like a chocolate bar?"
And women are much more likely to take the
chocolate bar if they were reminded of their
success.
The same studies been shown for procrastination.
You have people that keep track and feel good
about their progress that they've made on
a task and they're much more likely to choose
not to work on it.
And this is the goal switching hypothesis.
The idea is that any willpower challenge is
a competition between these two versions of
yourself and they're both you.
And as soon as your mind realizes that one
of you is satisfied because you made some
progress, the other goal becomes primed in
your brain and it becomes more appealing.
So I don't wanna say don't keep track of your
success cause I think, what I really wanna
encourage you to do is both.
But let me just, let me point to a couple
other ideas along this line.
Okay, so about why pessimism can be so helpful
because it's profoundly un-American to be
pessimistic when you have a goal and I just
wanna encourage you to think about using pessimism
as actually a source of willpower.
So there's this kind of finding floating around
that people who are most optimistic about
their ability to make a difficult change,
give up sooner and are most likely to fail
and it tends to be because they are shocked
by their setbacks.
So one of the ways that predicting failure
can be helpful is that when it happens it's
not like some shock to your system where you
can't believe it happened, it must say something
bad about who you are or about your likelihood
of success in the future.
There's also interesting studies, as I mentioned
that optimism, well this is both progress
and optimism, but studies show that if you
have people making optimistic predictions
about what they're going to do, they're more
likely to then not do it today.
So people who intend to exercise tomorrow
are more likely to eat something unhealthy
today and skip the gym.
Even just having people think about what they're
gonna do in their future makes people more
likely to make a different choice today.
So just knowing that you're gonna be just
as tempted tomorrow, you're gonna be just
as busy tomorrow, just as stressed out tomorrow
turns out to be an important source of willpower
today.
Okay, then this, I just had to throw this
in cause I think this is one of the funniest
findings in the willpower research.
That 75 percent of corporations that are investigated
by the SEC for fraud can be tracked by to
initial optimism that then people were unwilling
to let go of.
They were so optimistic about profit, their
profit projections, that when they met their
first setback they didn't know what to do
and they started to fudge the numbers.
And this is something that we all do with
our own goals when we set very high ideals
and then refuse to adjust our expectations
based on reality.
This is something I run into a lot at Stanford,
people say they wanna make big change or they
have a big goal in mind and they aren't the
least bit interested in setting a small goal
or a baby step cause how is that gonna ever
get me where I want?
So let's go big or go home.
And then when they start to run into problems
with that huge level of success, they kind
of hang on to the ideal and yet end up doing
nothing.
So you can think of yourself as your own little
corporation with goals and if you find yourself
hitting setbacks one of the most important
things you can do is adjust your expectations
and take a really serious look at the process
of how failures working.
So here is, um, here is an example form that
exercise study that's a little broadened out
and this is basically the writing exercise
those women were doing that doubled the amount
of time they were putting into their goal.
And they were supposed to do this writing
exercise every day.
The first is to identify your goal and what
would be a really positive outcome of that?
So you gotta get your motivation on board,
right?
Then what are you gonna do to take it?
So you set some clearly defined steps and
then you spend some time thinking about how
is this not going to happen.
When and where and why?
Is there anything you can do in advance to
prevent that failure?
And when failure happens, what are you gonna
do about it?
You don't actually have to make it 7 full
steps like this but it's a very basic exercise
that you can do for any goal.
I think of it as being like stress testing
a goal.
You have a goal, you say you're gonna do something,
well now put it to the test and find out how
it's gonna break, how it's gonna fail.
Okay, last intervention.
Let's all do it together unless you have health
problems and, you know, I don't want anyone
to pass out or have a stroke.
So if you are willing to take this challenge
we're just gonna hold our breath for 15 seconds.
Whose got a second hand?
Great!
You're gonna time us.
Okay, only if you wanna do this.
Take a deep breath in.
Look at your second hand, go ahead and take
a deep breath out, now exhale, exhale, exhale
it out, stop breathing.
Time us.
Remember you can breathe anytime you want
to if you need to.
I just want you to notice how this feels.
3, 2, 1 breathe.
Good, okay, so holding your breath obviously
that's a little bit of a willpower challenge.
Some of you maybe need to hold your breath
for two minutes to feel it but I did not want
anyone passing out.
So would you believe that this ability to
hold your breath is one of the best predictors
of people's ability to succeed at difficult
goals?
It's kind of interesting.
Psychologists call this distress tolerance.
The ability to stay put when things get uncomfortable.
So I wanna tell you now about a small intervention
that teaches people how to sort of hold their
breath but not exactly, how to basically ride
out physical discomfort that gets in the way
of making a difficult change.
I'm gonna tell you about two different studies
that are basically using the same technique.
So you can kind of pick your willpower challenge
here.
The first I call the torture chamber and this
is the study of smokers that wanted to quit
but had been unable to.
And the researches asked the smokers to abstain
from smoking for 24 hours, sort of a first
challenge and then to come into the laboratory
with a fresh unopened pack of their favorite
brand of cigarettes.
So all the smokers show up, they've got their
pack, they are desperate for a smoke, and
they even like carbon monoxide tested them
to make sure they hadn't smoked, so they had
all, they were ready for a cigarette.
They all get, they seated at a long table
and asked to put away all distractions except
for a lighter or a match and their cigarettes.
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: So you've got a bunch of
smokers now they're ready.
And then the experimenter is about to begin
the process of allowing them to smoke and
she says, actually through a microphone like
that, you hear this voice that says, "Take
out your pack of cigarettes" And everyone
does, they're all excited, "Woo hoo!"
"Stop!"
Okay
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: They have to wait 2 minutes
now and they're not allowed to do anything
except look at their pack of cigarettes.
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: "Pull off the cellophane!"
"Okay, great, whew!"
"Stop!"
Two minutes they have to wait.
"Pack it" Oh, there was pack, I don't smoke
so I forget some of these steps, they had
to pack the pack, too and they got the cellophane
open, okay.
"Take out a cigarette" "Finally!"
"Stop!"
They have to wait 2 minutes and this goes
on and every two minutes they're writing down
how intense their cravings are and how much
they want to smoke but other than that they're
not allowed to do anything.
"Take a cigarette out" "Stop!"
Two minutes.
"Look at the cigarette" "Stop!"
"Smell the cigarette."
"Stop!"
Two minutes.
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: "Put the cigarette in your
mouth" "Stop!"
Two minutes.
"Take out a lighter, look at it."
"Stop!"
Two minutes.
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: This went on for over an
hour.
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: Nobody was actually allowed
to light the cigarette, okay.
So here's what, I didn't tell you what the
actual intervention was yet, half of them
before this happened had been taught a technique
called surfing the urge in which you learn
to pay attention to the physical discomfort
of wanting something, you give it your full
attention and you trust that you can tolerate
those physical sensations and if you just
wait with patience they will go away.
That any craving, any emotion will eventually
pass if you can just breathe and wait, wait
it out.
But you don't have to act on every impulse
or emotion.
So that's the technique they were taught,
they were surfing the urge, they were imagining
those cravings as a wave that they were getting
on and they were just gonna breathe and they
knew that would eventually end just like a
wave.
Before I tell you the result of this study,
let me just give you the food one.
The food one's a little bit different.
They took people who have had problems with
self control around food, especially sweets,
gave them a clear container of Hershey's Kisses,
a transparent container and they had to carry
that box of Hershey's Kisses around with them
for 48 hours and were not allowed to eat a
single one and they were all carefully marked,
little pin scratch so the researchers would
know if they ate them and restocked it which
would not be cool.
[Laughter]
>>Kelly McGonigal: And they were taught the
same technique about how to handle cravings.
How to surf the urge, allow yourself to feel
the craving and yet remember you don't need
to act on it and the craving will go away
eventually.
Okay, so the results.
In this study, the smokers who'd been taught
how to surf the urge in that one hour torture
test, they ended up reducing their cigarette
smoke by 40 percent in the very next week
even though the researchers had not asked
them to.
The control group did not reduce their cigarettes
at all and interestingly in the people would
learn to surf the urge, there was now no longer
a connection between psychological stress
and smoking which is actually, that's the
main connection for most people who are trying
to quit, they're stressed out, they're anxious
and so they need a cigarette.
And in this particular group with this intervention,
it cut that link between stress and giving
in probably because they had a tool for dealing
with difficult feelings and emotions.
In this study, the people who had trouble
with self control around food, if they were
taught to surf the urge, 0 had a single Hershey's
Kiss over the entire 48 hours whereas those
who'd been given other strategies including
distraction ended up much more likely to give
in and also really stressed out about it.
So these are just two different examples about
how surfing the urge can give us a lot of
willpower for the things where we need willpower.
You know, a lot of times I hear people talk
about how important it is to build good habits
but the reality is sometimes you need strength
to do something difficult and there's no habit
in the world that's gonna make you not want
a cigarette when you see it or want a donut
when you see it or maybe you wanna avoid something
cause you're anxious.
There's a real impulse and a real feeling
that you need to deal with and this power
of acceptance seems to be the best strategy
for dealing with these difficult emotions,
these difficult thoughts and these difficult
cravings.
And any attempt to kind of push them away
or get rid of them backfires but being able
to ride them out and imagine them as passing
experiences that you don't need to act on
has been shown to help a lot of different
willpower challenges including the kind of
anxiety that leads us to not do things we
know we should do.
Intrusive thoughts, you know, that's a real
willpower challenge.
Sometimes our mind goes places we don't want
it to go, to memories or to things we're imagining
or to negative thoughts about ourselves and
others and research shows you can apply the
same technique to a negative thought without
having to act on it.
It's been shown to improve weight loss, it
actually, this technique of learning how to
accept your own cravings, tripled the long
term one year weight loss success rate among
people who were in a really standard weight
loss program.
It helped substance abuse and it even helps
people with schizophrenia.
I mean, talk about a willpower challenge when
you have voices in your own head that you
cannot escape and you're trying desperately
to have some kind of normal life and relationship
with the world when you've got these voices
in your head that are telling you to do something
or not to do something.
And studies show that schizophrenics who learn
to accept their own intrusive thoughts and
hallucinations and delusions, like a craving,
that's not real and you don't need to act
on it but it's gonna be there and eventually
it will pass, they actually end up being more
likely to be out of the hospital, be dehospitalized
and function normally compared to people who
have not been taught this technique.
Okay, so if you want to apply this technique
to any willpower challenge yourself, here's
what that small intervention would look like
for yourself.
Here's what people were taught in both of
those studies and the first is this mindfulness
to allow yourself to feel what you're feeling
or think what you're thinking and to actually
attend to the experience rather than immediately
try to escape it.
So if you're hungry, actually notice like,
what does hunger feel like in my body?
Or if you're anxious, what does anxiety feel
like in my body right now?
And then to actually just breathe, breathe
it out, use the breath as a source of stability.
You know what you're feeling, take a few breaths
and then broaden your attention out and look
for the first opportunity to recommit to your
goal, that's what they were taught in both
the smoking study and in the Hershey's Kiss
study and it's a technique that you can practice,
it takes like 30 seconds and it can help with
any sort of willpower challenge.
Okay, so just to wrap up, 5 willpower rules
and I would just invite you to think if you
heard anything today that might be relevant
to your willpower challenge, to give yourself
this short dose, this small dose intervention
and see how it works because that's actually
the nature of the class and the nature of
the book.
It's basically to become a willpower scientist
yourself, to get some ideas from the research
and then test it out.
I mean, you've got a hypothesis you can see
if it works or not, collect your own data.
So those five strategies, one is to train
your willpower physiology by meditating, by
sleeping, by exercising or by eating a diet
that's gonna sustain your energy.
Forgive yourself the next time you have a
willpower setback.
Make friends with your future self, kind of
think about the future in a way that feels
real.
Predict your failure even though it's really
nice to imagine success, really get interested
in the process of how you fail.
And then, finally, think about surfing the
urge when you are facing temptation.
And thank you, boy you guys, you waited it
out, you showed a lot of willpower sticking
around here.
[Laughter]
[Applause]